I never get scared if I got scared
they'd smell it they're like a beast in
a cage and if you get scared you lose
the battle with them instantly it really
is fascinating being up very closer
personal
touching some had chained up some arm
death could be a heartbeat away for you
they can lose the plot nobody having
corresponding with them sometimes for
years there is this interpersonal
relationship you know how far you can
push them you know what pushes their
buttons you know what annoys them and
it's about manipulation and mind control
they think they're in control but I'm in
control
Chris we have wrangled technology and
we've managed to make it work we finally
got ourselves down south so each other
correct yeah I'm a Scot surgeon there's
a first time for everything so this is
gonna be this evening so my first
question for you you've interviewed some
of history's most notorious killers
people like Peter Sutcliffe and Ted
Bundy Ilene warned us and Dennis Nelson
and Joanne Dennehy and stuff like that
if you're out for dinner with someone
new and they say so Chris what what do
you what do you do for work how do you
describe your job well it's actually a
bit of that it's great at parties or
barbecues because most people are
because that I've attended in the past
are sort of state agents and lawyers
golf club types and when they ask you
where their nose up in the air what do
you do for a job
asari interview serial killers and that
instantly attracts a massive crowd and
and I got a lot of fun of looking at
these accountants in their jaws drop on
the floor it's different isn't it it's
definitely different yeah I mean it must
be a you write a barbecue it must be a
very shocking thing to hear especially
just from you know I was prepared I'm
prepared to speak to you having done
some research on your background when
you were just expecting you to say oh
well actually I'm the area manager for
this accounting firm or I do yeah I mean
I'm in Laura or whatever it might be I
just speak to serial killers so but just
to clear one thing I don't normally go
to dues where people don't know me most
of the people I dine with when I get a
chance and I can't afford it is people
that do know me
I mean in the Philippines where I live
most of the year I mean I done with
police officers and people like that and
they all homicide cops the same I do but
some occasionally somebody says I think
I saw you on the TV you know you the
criminologist or something but to me
it's just another job Chris I mean it's
just another job
I suppose it is it's the same for
everyone right it's just par for the
course and so the first question the
burning question I've got for you is
what is it like to sit down and
interview these people even having had
this huge long illustrious career that
you have with a lot of experience is
there still is it still quite an odd
experience to go in and and also do you
get scared to answer the last question
first I never get scared if I got scared
they'd smell it they they can sense it
they're like a beast in a cage and if
you get scared you lose the battle with
them instantly because they're control
freaks they're Psychopaths and the
minute you do that you've got to come
down to their level straightaway it can
be fascinating it really is fascinating
and they're all different
being up very close to personal touching
somewhat chained up some arm death could
be a heartbeat away for you they can
lose the plot but it's knowing their
back history before you go there nobody
having corresponding with them sometime
for years so you there is this
interpersonal relationship you know how
far you can push them you know what
pushes their buttons you know what
annoys them and it's about manipulation
and mind control so I never get scared
I'm in control they think they're in
control but I'm in control you were you
had a good example of that the first
character in your new talking with
serial killers book dead man talking
John Robinson I think that was probably
a pretty good example of someone who
thought he was in control and they
turned the tables on him
yeah yeah homicidal dell boy yeah no you
describe him I said that actually on a
TV series I think things called born to
kill or something and I had the crew on
the floor of stitches and I said you're
gonna be babe
and they said yeah we leave it in that's
great so that's what he was so I mean
you did the game he received was he was
just full of [ __ ] I mean you know
he's a cartoon character really if you
if you take away all the horror of his
crimes and his manipulations there is
black humour there you know so why do
these serial killers open up to you at
all why why you well interesting
question I think if we come away from
serial killers we go to John Kernan who
murdered Shirley banks in Bristol
definitely the Suzy lamb clue and
certainly Sandra courting Bournemouth to
give you an idea when his case when he
was finally locked up for life I I wrote
to him to say that I wanted to write a
book about him
and he came back very cocky and said oh
well now I've got I've got dozens of
authors and publishers want my exclusive
story so then I got John Blake my
publisher that sort of send me some
pictures of my book covers and I sent
him those with a letter saying well
thanks very much I really wanted your
assistance I think you've been stitched
up by the police John I'll write the
story without your cooperation thanks a
lot so I put it between a rock and a
hard place and I try to use the same
fishing techniques with women and male
serial killers in finding out what their
wants and their needs are it's like
beach fishing you know where the fish
swim like Robinson you know what he
wants but it's a case of casting the
right bait to catch him
with Melanie McGuire's in that book the
ice queen she was in New Jersey upscale
woman good lifestyle chopped up a
husband threw him in bits and pieces in
the Chesapeake Bay but but but she had
hundreds of letters and publishers
wanting her so I wrote on conqueror
cream conqueror paper like this his lay
lady stuff his cream stuff with an
envelope and then I put my family crest
wax seal on it and I sprayed it with
them shonali go east so when she opened
a letter
she's got an airmail stamp from England
which makes it different
it's classy stationery she opens it and
this is sense this smell that she
remembers he go he stole yet and it's
something she'll come back to because
this it's a sensory thing so I used that
bait without it's interesting that you
managed to get yourself through the door
using by finding out what these people
want what it is that they want and then
dangling that but how about when you
actually sit down with them have you got
a process obviously you you tend to
spend a lot of time corresponding back
and forth but when you eventually do get
face to face with them what you know
what is it that you're doing what is it
that you're saying or the way that
you're acting which is encouraging them
to give away more than they usually
should what what are the tricks of the
trade if you like is one thing that law
enforcement my friends in the FBI will
tell you in the British piece you can't
use Britt police can't use entrapment
they can't use they can't entrap a
person
so but I can and and it's really about
making them feel comfortable with you
and you letting them know that although
that you're on their side but you know
you're not on their side and you are
chatting really and now that could be an
end game to it for me like with Arthur
Shawcross I wanted him to confess to a
murder of a little schoolboy called Jack
Blake I mean he told me you know it's a
language now but he was inches away from
me and the guard said if he loses the
plot he could tell you and of course a
friend and we won't be in the room now
we show across he literally boiled over
he went white his face went white sweat
pouring down his face when I mentioned
Jack Blake he told me not to ever
mention it otherwise he'd killed me and
he was but but I leaned forward and
touched his knee and I said come with
your girlfriend Clara's waiting outside
and she's asked me to be the best man at
your wedding Arthur and she's going to
go eight if you don't tell me the whole
truth and then his face is any teeth
there's a TV interview on you will see
it online on the program and and and um
he cracked and the fury went and he he
confessed and it's a case or sometimes
they'll eyeball you and they will say
something bragging about Mike Michael
roasted the strangulation marks multiple
marked round his victims necks he got a
kick out of that he giggled and then I
looked at him straight in the face and
said - and Mike you know you're not a
big serial killer really are you I mean
seven or eight you're not Ted Bundy give
me a break come aboard
just look stunned and then he went on to
try to describe more that way done you
know and and I got two cold cases I
teared up with him which were zoom not
too with Cornell University and a little
girl called Kimberly can be local
minimum crystal run so it depends how
you play I mean sometimes it's a serious
math because you're there to try to try
to bring closer to the next of kin and
you're the only point in the talk to it
so there is a heavy side of it it's seem
I mean this is the fact that you've said
that you don't get scared and yet there
is a guy that says I'll [ __ ] kill you
you know that the police are the de
Guard's far enough away for him to be
able to do some serious damage before
they could get in like that takes that
takes some balls well with Kenneth
Bianchi the notorious health hillside
strangler I interviewed him at the
Washington State Penitentiary in a small
room and there was only a wooden table
between us a small table and he's got
the eyes of a great white shower at and
they don't blink and you're looking into
the face of evil you can smell him and
he's a big guy he's strong they do
weights everyday at yard time you know
there are a lot of in idiots so anyway
he's sitting across this table and he's
eyeballing me and I just kept looking at
him and I got up and I walked back to
his side of the table I put my arm round
him and I whispered in his ear and I
said listen you find a miserable
[ __ ]
I said give me a small come on and he
cried and as he left the room after the
hour he turned round as the guards let
him out because I was the only one in
the room with him he terrorized if you
ever come near me again I'll kill him do
you think he meant my sword yeah by
throwing twice after that I saw him one
on exercise I went in snowing and they
walked he walked past and I'm sort of a
blue jacket with a bass book with a
woolly hat on a long long row of cons
and I literally was within feet of him
and he just looked down he wouldn't do
it would look at me then I saw him again
up on the special thousand you name and
he told me that he had a special house
which he calls his cell it was the best
seller in the whole prison in the
penitentiary because he was a top man
but really an I'm going to see his house
so I had the run of the prison even
death row man don't when I wanted to and
I walked up and the guard said
Christopher do not step over that yellow
line because they throw feces in PA
when I walk down the tier and I walk
back and then I cross the line I walked
up to Bianchi's tiny for the cell and he
was asleep on his bunk with headphones
on and I said come penny penny it's your
friend Chris I've come to see you in
your house he went ape you are a very
ballsy man an incredibly ballsy man I've
unlocked
I had unlocked because I had the run of
the place about seventeen major six
inmates on death row in the Washington
State Penitentiary and I sat down with
him in the semicircle on the floor got
some guard too got some coca-cola I've
got some candy in a sat down I've spoke
to the shop caller who the number one
column and bath week and I said to him
is it okay if I unlock and we can chat
and we sat down for nearly what people
do now maybe didn't discuss their crimes
just discuss life and everything no
threat at all no threat at all because
you've got to remember and you'll listen
to your viewers have got to remember
these people most of these men will kill
innocent women and children they will
not font up to a man all mouth they're
all mouth of trousers they're cowards
any man that kills young children or
elderly people or vulnerable gays is
nothing more than a coward a gutless
coward
so that's the way it works and that's
the one that's why it's important for
what you said at the beginning for you
to go in to not show fear to have this
image because that weakness is what
they're looking for exactly that's how
they screw up the psychiatrist brains
and minds because that they know they
can run rings around psychiatrists they
know a lot the time they can run rings
around the cops but what they can't do
is they get stuck in a corner with me
when they think Oh Christopher's gonna
write a book all about me it's going to
make a TV program I'm going to be famous
the stuff before they start that's the
point
until the next will not being on a
podcast with you and we're famous they
love it I mean probably probably keep me
anonymous if it's if it's okay keep
might keep my name anonymous but I guess
they're behinds ours what they gonna do
um so your new book dead men talking
looks at killers that are on death row
is there anything different about the
dynamic with these people in that
they're on death row rather than just
potentially serving life in prison what
they call many a Green Mile remember the
film the Stephen King the Green Mile
cause they're not green until their past
or shades sometimes they are not no
longer like we see in the Green Mile and
not so antiquated San Quentin the
condemned row of San Quentin State
Prison is pretty grim but there is a
certain amount of they are dead men
walking and they are they come to the
end of the line that their only hope is
that the Lord will save them and get
them a reduced sentence or off the hook
before they're given the good night
juice so there is that certain quietness
now if you come down a level rap a level
from death row you get a special housing
units where they're completely bonkers
and it's like being at London Zoo on a
crazy day they're screeching and
throwing [ __ ] at each now they're and
howling and spitting stuck a madhouse is
that with the ones with psychiatry
problems no not all of them that's just
like but the death row inmates are like
oh let's just say them all they got more
respect
they've done the ultimate crime now they
may be a child killer then they're gonna
be sort of put to one side but the point
is there is that sort of a hierarchy in
the prison system where death row inmate
is when I go to interview a death row
inmate they look down to prison if I
want him out of his cell there's a
complete lockdown of the whole facility
nothing moves and then they bring the
inmate shackled with guards mac-address
guards either side of them and he
shackled up and they bring to you and it
will be up to me whether I decide
whether I want them comfortable and
unshackled or I want to get the Mubarak
a knee or coca-cola and quite often I'll
tell the guards get him this or get him
that and the inmate likes that because
the guards are telling the inmate what
to do every day and here am i telling
them what to do but it's all prearranged
it's all like a soap opera River so it
gives give that impression that you're
on their side look this is us working
together I'm one of you etc etc so do
you tend to prefer to have the inmates
without restraints to make them feel
more comfortable when you can yeah I
think one of the only I mean sometimes
get behind a screen and like Kenneth and
Macduff
at death row Ellis unit before he was
executed in Texas he was behind
somewhere behind screens which is great
don't this plot the sunset Slayer in San
Quentin prison he was heavily shackled
but he he was going ape I mean he was
really in a foul mood it took me ages to
calm him down before we got the cameras
rolling but with dougie it was a matter
of him attacking the guards not
attacking me so that's the difference
with Michael Ross and some of the other
killers like Shawcross and some of the
others I will say look if you're gonna
behave yourself or get the shackles
taken off and we'll get some code and
we'll get some candy down here and we're
gonna have a nice comfortable chair but
don't mess me about because you'll go
back down the hole and then that's it I
get it okay so we've got a good
understanding there of the process of
how you're speaking to them how you
build rapport stuff like that I want to
get into the actual pathology the way
that these guys and these women think
first question is is there a common
theme among serial killers upon reading
this most recent book of yours they come
from all i q-- points there's different
backgrounds there's different approaches
you got one person one killer who's
putting people into barrels to leave
them to liquidate and they're on fluids
you've got another that's eating the
ears of the victims that he kills you
know it seems to be all over the place
so what are the commonalities are are
there any can I ask you a question we're
social distancing at the moment aren't
we yes an email yes can i smoke because
i like a cigarette absolutely that's up
so you fine by me i thought the smoke
trap failure no no at all i can't i
can't smell it through the through the
microphone anyway alright okay they're
different psychopathologies okay down a
little under stein they're all totally
different
there they are every single one of them
you tried to look for something common
amongst them and he can't find it what
they will tell you is that they were
abused as a child or had a bad
upbringing or they were badly
potty-trained or they were only allowed
to drink green top milk but they wanted
blue top now there's all sorts of
[ __ ] excuses for why they do what
they do
you've got Peter Sutcliffe saying it was
the Word of God when he was digging the
grave that killed prostitutes but then
he didn't just cope working girls did he
he killed he killed innocent ordinary
girls classy girls and the same with
Harvey the hammer the carrot ha me that
hammer carrington in the Minnesota
Correctional Facility 50 victims when he
went to trial he said that God told him
to kill these women and he wore a white
robe and some liver from sandals and
when when he got sentenced to life in
prison his lawyers had to go for another
trial and his law paramount from the
said Oh Harvey said God didn't help me
last time I don't think about me next
time I mean I are some I mean I know
it's black humor but I mean UT it's
serious subject but you know when when
you're there when they're exhumed in a
body that you helped get out of the
ground like in Waco the cops are
actually very very loving and careful
with the course and everything else but
there is a little bit of black humor
going around and I asked do too because
it releases the pressure because then as
well so there what the answers are quite
short they're all different it's an
interesting one what I found to be
interesting was that some of the
murderers are so brutal toward their
victims and yet they have families they
have children that they care about or
that at least they don't mistreat for
instance John Robinson who is the full
eighty pages dedicated to him and he's
got a wife of like 20 years five killed
and yet alongside that was committing
all of these atrocious crimes yeah but
no I think that's an easy one to answer
and I think your your viewers were going
to love this bit they don't love them
how can you love a woman and commit
adultery for 13 years and going around
raping and killing women that he's
learning to his web of deceit how can
any man love a woman or love their chill
if they doing that
BTK another one the Green River Killer
no got found this I've just written a
book coming out soon called sleeping
with cereal because it's about women who
live with these men all that because
thinking about Sonia Sutcliffe god bless
her I mean I know she's caused a lot of
problems but she never knew that Peter
was a serial killer until the police
knocked on it you know arrested them
happy new love how can you love a woman
or a woman love a man and then commit
those terrible crimes it does I tell you
what it is Chris it's a matter of
wearing a mask of normality its
presenting yourself to your neighbors
and your business colleagues I'm married
and I've got kids look we've got a nice
house we could mow the yard every Sunday
we go bar because let me go charge but
it's all [ __ ] because it's hiding
the monster living within it's the mask
of evil
it's it's like that large it's their
social camouflage it's like the ghillie
suits that a gamekeeper will use when
he's shooting to hide himself I was in
the publishing I've got really this
really quite a lovely little thing I was
at Manila and I went to this big massive
aquarium it's one of the best in the
world and I was looking all these little
glass cases in the critical reception
and as you notice I've got glasses on my
eyes like it's not the best and I was
peering through this glass trying to see
something in it he was like sand and
there was like twigs and I couldn't see
anything I kept looking to see if it
exhibit clothes or something but they're
tucked away little two black eyes
peering out of the sand waiting for
another creep to call we could come
along and kill it or a little tweak
thing that moved and that's what serial
killers are like the camera flashed
nobody sees them nobody knows they there
nobody knows they're coming and then
they strike it seems unbelievable that
you could be the partner of a murderer
an abuser someone who has this crazy
other side to their world and not know
but as you've identified there are
examples well so how can you not you
know it to me I just think why didn't I
wouldn't someone have thought well the
thing is in a lot of places a lot of
places the red flag that's a lot of
coated the woman will know honey he's
doing something strange today or he's
not acting right all this money missing
out the bank and wonder what he's doing
there are red flags a fortune a lot of
women don't spot those red flags that's
what this book about the secret of
killers is about it's looking at the red
flags and Michael Sams who killed um the
young prostitute in them in the middle
of Yorkshire wife you're certainly red
flag 14 the sand so I interview
I'm if my Sam's we feel that prison
there were so many red flags there she
just ignored him he troubled over her he
conned and lied in everything else he
didn't love her but the mini he got
locked up in prison outcome all the love
letters I miss you blah blah but can you
send me some money team
I want these railway magazines at the
same time and the Sunday newspaper
there's a picture of a woman called
Vicky VIN celli who had bust about a 44
parading herself outside the prison
gates a visit and it's Michael Sams two
piece of stuff I I'm blown away by this
I am since reading the book I've been
thinking a lot about our modern-day
obsession with serial killers with true
crime the popularity of series on
podcasts like cereal and open vanished
it's huge there is this resurgence or a
surgeons in popularity in this and I put
tweet out about it and got sent
literally just before we came live I got
sent a photo of a t-shirt that a girl
said to me this is exactly what you were
talking about and it's a girls t-shirt
that says probably eating or thinking
about serial killers I was like that's
it right there like that I know so many
girls that love true crime Kaduri
what do you think it is three the
extreme of that I mean everybody's
entitled to that but what are called
murder groupies so you've got hundreds
of women of writing and men are writing
to women killers as well like the
retired major from bubbly soaps turn
he's trying to some hooker in prison
serving life he's seen a beautiful she
sent him beautiful pictures which are
really some fake ones of a girl in a
Russian model he thinks he's falling in
love he's sending that money you got the
murder groupies you've got that motor
groupies have married these people in
prison they want the killers baby's
safety what they don't well because they
just possess the dispossessed
I mean Keith hunter Jesperson the happy
face killer neither one of my guys he
has hundreds of girls he's six foot four
seven I think the truck interstate
trucker he sent the files of love length
to some photographs of the girls
boasting about all look another one
wants
me and other ones coming to visit next
week and one of them and this is quite
disgusting was what I thought was a
lipstick imprint on the note paper i
factor written about this in the book
and I I thought somebody just given them
a kiss with lipstick on and he wrote
underneath were not for a surah he said
that oh that's not lipstick that it's
menstrual blood
well that's two firsts that we can chalk
up this evening Christopher your first
podcast and the first time in about 200
episodes that the term menstrual blood
has ever been used so I mean what is
going on what is the obsession here is
it that the the women find this level of
dominance and aggression and and
undiluted masculinity attractive is that
what it is Jim now you asked me a
question I haven't got the answer
because I can't get inside I mean I
don't understand women at the best of
times their rights to some cannibal in
the diner or some woman I mean that was
Arthur Shawcross I mean the girl way to
marry him but the thing is they don't
seem to get it
they don't think oh I better go and look
at the scenes of crime photographs and
see if I can get those through the
Freedom and formation act in America or
go online and see what what he did to
these people
that's stupid I said thick stupid it's
dangerous man it really is as he was
about 80 year old women writing to some
what the big black hunk in Florida who
calls himself Florida's finest chocolate
and she's in love with him and he's he's
she's sending him money every week but
he's got a dozen or so women like
sending him money
it is a luma see here I ought to be what
that they ought to sit in an electric
chair for ten minutes and see what it
feels like I'm doing something wrong
here because I'm 32 and single and these
guys have just got hareem's of women
chasing after them giving them money
real chocolate or whatever he's called
over in Florida having a whale of a time
big difference you're imprisoned in your
own home like I am right now they're
gonna SiC electric chair
that's true um so we understand that
there aren't necessarily any
commonalities between the killers the
way that they the reasons that they kill
their justification for it both publicly
and privately are all different
what about commonalities between the
victims that they go for you mentioned
that they tend to be weaker people like
women children yeah the elderly the
vulnerable in society um most serial
killers have what they call their own
victimology their own preferred victim
type now your viewers can go online and
they can look up Ted Bundy's victims and
you'll see they almost look all of them
by sisters sorority sisters in fact they
were Mostyn were sorority sisters you
couldn't have a reminder map they'd all
look the same
long hair same look same ages that sort
of thing that's what turned Bundy on
that's all you've got Henry Lucas and
Ottis Toole now I interviewed Henry when
our dear ol Henry downing them floor in
Texas Molly what was on the row he was
subsequently given a life sentence then
he died of natural causes rather than
I'm President Lee was the governor then
was Bush I think it was but but they
went for everything I mean they know
they they ready to murder chickens and
dogs and cats and young girls and
children and old men and old ladies I
mean they they went through the whole
shebang they did everything
there's a lot of fried chickens in Texas
I can tell you that's that is that dark
humor that we were talking about again
isn't it why is there often an element
of sex involved in the crimes and is
there is it almost always that there's
some sort of sexual gratification going
on with stereo killers certainly the I
think the only serial killer I've ever
interviewed that wasn't sexually
motivation was John scripts from the
Isle of Wight he was 34 years old
I watched him being hanged in Changi
Prison years ago it was on my birthday
18th of April funny enough happy birth
happened the piece gave me presentation
mode when I left the country with him
with a picture of a man hanging from a
tree but but John he he killed for money
he he gone to can come and he murdered a
young uni guy called Timothy McDowell
got into his PIN numbers and then he
chopped and fitted to the alligators
then later on in his he went to prison
then years later for drug smuggling he's
got 15 years but he walked out of a
prison an open prison about two years
later after telling everybody he was
going to escape he just walked out they
go no joke any notice um and he was
taught butchery skills on the Isle of
Wight by a prison officer called Quigley
and he learned how to dismember
carcasses were in prison so the prison
taught him how to dismember victims so
he then went to Singapore where he met a
South African businessman called Gerard
George Lowe who was in Singapore by an
electrical stuff because it was cheaper
back in those days it's not anymore it's
more expensive but then it was and and
they shared the same hotel room and then
John hit him with a Campion hammer and
then got this pin number of extracted
his pin number out of him and then he
took dragged him into the bathroom and
then he stuck a knife in his neck and
led him to death chopped him up put them
in suitcases and dumped him into the
into the Singapore by
then he went straight to did a bit more
shopping went to the Opera on his
business card
he went to Thailand he went to Phuket he
met Sheila and her son Darren her mood
it was on the Gatley because he broke
his leg I stayed at Millie's in Lily's
marina in in Phuket on the beach there I
killed them both he stunned him with a
stun gun dismembered them put their
bodies down a mineshaft
but lucky Nene he went back to Singapore
and by then the body who bought the body
parts of Jared load popped up in the
singapore harbour Gerard Lim detective
Superintendent Jared Allen who I know
very well he put out hotel call for
anybody not paying their bills the name
of Lo and he trapped they caught John
and then they hanged him and I might
have you John on the Monday before his
execution and I said from John why
didn't you appeal he said they won't
hang me Chris on British 4th ridings
they tore his head office what they hunt
him between two tight bands he refused
to be wait for the drop he but he did
put up a spirited file they broke his
nose in his jaw they put these strips in
naked and then he put them on the drop
between two tide bandits and he wants a
Time Bandits re-type tuck there were
ties to my bandits sorry him yes not the
ones you get from a shot like to cut I
shop and and then and then what happened
was they I was doing some stuff with apt
vehicles I covered the execution and I'm
and then I went to the cremation and
interviewed the Thai ambassador and then
they had to bring his ashes back to
England so we we had a little drawer who
was going to keep the ashes in their
bedroom but I rigged it I didn't want on
but I think they hang John yeah because
he refused to be wise head was really
what's wrong
broken nose broken jaw naked hung
crapping himself
the other two guys were standing there
as good as gold a Papa fightin the
priest at the time had been there for
years and years and years and he came
outside and he wept and he said to me
Christmas Chris he said I'm never going
to go to an execution again that was
terrible
the struggle and the the fact that it
didn't go down smoothly is that what
disturbed the priests yeah it was awful
I've seen a few executions in my time
shootings I mean I was in the Marines
for years I've seen a lot of executions
and terrible things but that was an
execution that you know you look at it
in this thing right the reason he was
naked was because they they they told
him to get out of his prison shorts
he had flip-flops and prison laws big
ism
if he went to the gals with those you
saw all the shorts and then they got a
washer so they told him to put his
civilian clothes on and he said no and
with that they just dragged him out
himself whole load of him breathing the
hell out of them he didn't he bleep up a
fight
whether capital punishment is justified
or not is it sort of a much longer
question for a different time but that
does seem a little
barbaric to have someone naked in the
21st century being hanged yeah I mean
Jessie de Ferro in America he went up in
flames because the electric chair was
all it was like them it worked well
acquiring in the Green Mile it was
exactly the same scenario the bloke
caught fire
squealing wasn't properly calibrated
wasn't whitened no no they just it was a
basta old electric chair they tried to
fix it but they would repair it properly
and then fried him to death I see I mean
that happens but but the point is on the
Metro capital punishment I'm quite often
asked that question and I always say
look it's none of our damn business if
the people in Texas are sick and tired
of having their little babies in their
mothers and their wives no elderly
people killed for a pocketful of change
by scar and these people know like John
Scripps did when he went to Singapore
there are signs everywhere you you you
break our law you drug smuggling or
murder we will hang you don't matter
what now these people aren't insane when
they commit these crimes Chris they know
what they're doing is wrong all the all
and why should I
legislate for people in Texas that's not
for them to decide
just like we wouldn't expect people to
tell us to bring back hanging here it's
not if it's horse of courses but these
people
I mean Hindley and Brady should have
been a hum no doubt about it
what horrific crimes they carried out
they should have been hung but there are
people out the safe oh no no God
wouldn't like that you know we're all
equal in the eyes of God well you tell
that to the parents of those murdered
children to releasing I think the most
the only compelling argument that I
think I've heard against capital
punishment is to do with the retribution
versus rehabilitation argument that on
one side is a it's the law enacting
revenge on behalf of the public as
opposed to it being an opportunity to
try and rehabilitate people but as
you've mentioned there there are crimes
that are so heinous and people who are
so far gone that you think well what
solve it what is left to salvage of this
person the first thing that your viewers
must understand and she cannot reform or
rehabilitate the psychopath it's
impossible that's a fact of life
second thing you should realize is that
when these people commit these crimes
they know exactly what the punishment
could be whether acts as a deterrent or
not that in that knowledge is another
matter it didn't act as a term for John
scripts so the offender makes the
decision judge Stewart Naumann Long
Island one day and he's a hard-nosed
judge East and that was just judge stark
he told me he said to me Chris society
makes the laws we have to live by these
laws otherwise is anarchy if an offender
committed a heinous crime and knows that
the death penalty is applicable
then we really we merely provide the
rope he's made a decision and it sucked
him a simple analogy would be if you
park your car on double yellow line and
get a ticket don't complain about it you
knew what you were doing was wrong
that's a simple analogy you're right
you are right I want to ask of across
your very long career kind of hitting
the big the big players in the world of
murder and depravity who are some of the
ones that disturbed you the most or that
played on your mind the most none of the
ones I've interviewed a played on my
mind none and so I think I mean you're
on Blake another one of my poem
published by Blake Barney but John Blake
the male published in John Blake is just
commissioned me to write a book called
210 worst serial killers in the world I
mean yeah I'm doing it I think what one
of the most heinous killers of all time
was Peter Kurten German go
I narrowed there is there are deeper
pride monsters and now are the devil
spawn
and Curtin was one of them
the ante he murdered also two little
schoolgirls in rocks Angeles with Angela
bono I went to the body dumping site
above the canal now the laws of Peter
and Sonia Johnson twelve years old
Hey
well while bono rate one little girl the
other girl said to Ken outside the
bedroom door where Sonia and Bianchi
smugly looked her and said you'll be
seeing her in a minute the last thing in
a little schoolgirl show was a dead
mutilated little friends laying on the
bed beside her they dumped the bodies
naked on the hillside and I've described
I've got the same two grand for a car
flip described I went out with Leroy
Roscoe that lead detective the film crew
and the body thumping site was a place
where they dump trash and it was a sign
right next to all says no dumping of
rubbish here and yet there's all this
garbage scared and two little girls I
mean that is so sick he can't imagine it
that's not the German guy though right
or was that the German the last one I
just read that was kept another Bianca
they also strangler yep now he he's
married three women in prison and they
divorced him and he fleeced them of
money and now is an ordained priest and
a member of the American Bar Association
now get your head around that so this is
this the multi-faceted life that serial
killers seemed to lead Ted Bundy self
representing you know saying I I'm gonna
put my own case forward I'd like to do
my own getting rid of his representation
at the time and then deciding that he
was going to step up and you know
someone that it becomes ordained and
then passes the bar like the there's
obviously a lot of momentum behind these
individuals they have capacity to do
things it's just that it's directed into
such a heinous destructive path tell me
back to Bundy was too clever for his own
good um when eventually placed for all
when he eventually was arrested down in
Florida and I went to that up into
économique a house where he killed her
he's illyrian Bowman and attempt to kill
another one and I'm interviewed the cops
there as well quite interesting and
think I met his lawyer
it was the prosecutor of a lawyer and he
said Oh Kris is something you might be
interested in he said this is what what
got Bundy the electric chair I thought
what's this then and he held out a pair
of white dentures cast by casts
he said yeah no doesn't reduce ELISA
some teeth said that's Ted Bundy's
original dentures that were taken after
he was arrested I said to Gloria I said
well he didn't have to give those to you
did he you know he said we calmed him he
said we told him because he was famous
and the press are being funded from the
cameras all the time he should look his
best and his teeth really need some work
so they took and he agreed because he
was vain and he was a narcissistic
little pig
and so they took these dentures but then
he compared those dentures with the bite
marks on these Olivia's buttocks and
that was the death sentence too clever
for example I remember I remember
watching that in the documentary and
hearing you speak about these
individuals and the way that you write
as well in the book it's very evocative
you you put your own opinion into the
way that you describe them as well and I
don't know whether it's simply because
it's not my profession and I've never
been exposed to them but I just can't
get over how ballsy it is it to me it
just it seems like such a brave thing to
do to speak and I know it's stupid like
Ted Bundy's gone I can say whatever I
want about him but there's part of me
that fears still fears even the essence
of them does that make sense part of me
that wants to almost distance myself
from from saying anything for fear that
this creature in the night's going to
somehow come in an actor retribution
person believe I have got a nicked copy
of Gideon's Bible which I carry and I
supposed to make it Christopher come on
[Laughter]
promise your honor
I promise when the maid came and cleared
out the room and she was asking me I
said no you know I said I'm a
god-fearing person and I think she
probably thought it was it was my Bible
then she was very kind of put in there
and as I was on the flight
that's a UK from Philippines oh I
thought well I better keep it when I do
I do pray every night I mean I do I do
pray I mean I was on a particularly
horrible homicide in Manila this late
last year yeah Halloween last year a
friend of mine I went through he is
worse at the American Embassy asked me
could I go and visit had a homicide in
Makati in Manila the working girl had
being axed tortured could did some promo
I did a bit of crying profiling I've got
some photographs of meeting with a major
they treated me like gold and he's got
some of my books now but what we called
the guards the German guy it was it
wasn't hard but they're not particularly
crying profile oriented out there in the
Philippines what they do is they catch
somebody then they she look dead they
don't worry you know and but this was a
particularly hot I mean I saw the girl
died she was beautiful she was a working
girl she was only 32 here to kiddie she
had to go on the streets to her money
she's absolutely stunningly beautiful in
life and they tied her up tortured her
and the last thing that she did was one
one eye open and the tear ran down her
cheek and then she died when the we got
the guy within three days it wasn't
difficult to profile him because her
body ended up a long way from where she
was last seen in a nightclub
so that stands that the person must have
had his own car and then with we got the
CCTV in there with other witnesses and
there was a tall guy thought he was
German with the tattoo on his shoulder
and me and the guy from the embassy
American Embassy sat down with his girls
because they were reluctant to talk to
the police and one of them happened to
mention in passing all these friends on
Facebook
what crack they went through the
Facebook and
the list of contacts this girl so sick
that's it now the thing was always
flying back on the Sun be on the seventh
II think it was a business class flight
to Dubai and then back to London with
the Emirates and that morning the police
were going to raid they're going to
catch him that midday so we're going to
get Chris and they and they said we're
going to smash it they go SWAT teams out
there they go for it and anime just said
look Chris he said you can have my gun
he said and if I shoot him if you like
I mean it don't miss about out there
every mission not messing about at all
no I'm telling you this is God's truth
later I learned I said well he had got a
life sentence I said oh well not really
and at what they do is they take them to
court in I could pick up a truck we were
just a tarpaulin on the top and wooden
benches besides are up because it's hot
and took a motorcycle through the past
pillion passenger you up alongside with
crash Amazon and shot as it blew his
head off that was it please why bother
with the trial I talk a lot quicker and
simpler to just kill them on the way
there yeah saves all the probability
embassies and all this or staff
announcing gun and dusted that is insane
and so tell us about the the German
fella that you mentioned the one that
you said was pretty disturbing
Peter Kurten if you look up evil and
depraved in a Rosetta Thoris for
depravity and they look at all the
synonyms that go all the way down that
list he's one of them in fact if you
look up deprived in the dictionary Peter
curtains face will be looking back at
you why
he was I can tell you because of just
our chaps running on put how can one
possibly so much sailor sexual serial
killer Peter Cohen and an effort to
answer this question one might require
roses the source and lookup depraved
fenced and cinemas running along these
lines sexual pervert beastly an evil
genius vile base corrupt contemptible
murderous etc etc a putrid nauseous
loathsome diabolic example of the devil
spawn might be asked that for point
fairly big headline fairly big headline
a very nasty little man what did he do
honey write your babies the kids and
he'd go round the really delayed and
drop the head off a swan and drink my
blood I means a vampire he was a he was
into digging up bodies and eating lots
of bodies not after each murder um I
mean this guy was really and he lived
with it is woman in live with his wife
he is she never suspected a thing he
said he said sure he raped babies and
set them on fire let me screw him to
death I mean that's not good is it
but they did chop his head off chopped
his head off in Germany near the
guillotine yeah is that still going is
German or its psychiatrist doctor can't
yet execute doctor Carrboro called him
the king and this is his doctor called
him the king of sexual perverts
that's his doctor you don't hear that
every day from your local GP do you I
should open up um that is incredible
so that's that I mean that seems like
it's really you know even Ted Bundy
wasn't cutting the head off swans and
drinking their blood and setting babies
on fire after raping them so he we
automatically people automatic when you
ask any button I get hundreds of
messenger I always answer messenger I
always write back to my readers so I
mean it can be quite a long time but my
readers are my customers and I value
them very much in fact without us and
both publishes we would not be in
business without readers so I got a new
viewers of the same you know we would
not be in business if it wasn't for your
people so we found you them a hundred
percent but
you know we we got to learn about these
people there's no good shot Midori
pretending they're not there but what is
bad and I will say this now there was a
man called Colin pitchfork who murdered
two schoolgirls in the Midlands years
ago he raped him and killed him he got a
natural life sentence he's now walking
around amongst us under an assumed name
the guy that killed
killed that little boy a young that
shopping mall years ago
Bridgewater car Bridgewater he's out and
about in society
he lives not far from me you mentioned
earlier on you said Psychopaths are
essentially irredeemable yeah there's
nothing and I think it was I want to say
Arthur Shawcross but it might not be
someone that was part of one of the
series that you're involved in I was
watching earlier on and they were let
out after it's serving 18 months of good
behavior and upon that happening then
re-entered innocence still crossed in 15
years of the 23 year sentence and and
the psychiatrist said the parole board
always fit to be released me where I'm
killed about well prostitutes very well
may have been nice I mean what like what
what does this mean for the how are we
supposed to litigate against this you
know what do we do well the problem is
what you've got to remember and I've say
this in my books and I'll say it to you
now and I'll tell you what the reason I
say it on TV is well after time the
psychiatrist and there's people that
haven't got a clue
they live on another planet they live in
a world where liberals bounce fairies
reign supreme and elephants fly they're
fools
in in fact in some of the cases the
psychiatrists and walk mad that the
people they're representing or analyzing
and that's the fact getting it wrong the
price of getting this sort of an
assessment wrong or being outwitted by a
serial killer is 15 lives as you just
identified with Arthur chakra don't
cross wheedled is way to the prison
start yet for you now and he learned the
psychobabble speak and he and he was
counseling other inmates
this is a fact and so when it came up
for parole
always reformed heat we've spun ready
arm to them next minute he's killing
prostitutes by handful chewing their
vaginas he spitting the bones out and go
eating dunkin doughnuts for the cops and
listening to who they're trying to catch
yeah that was it so there was this story
about one of the cops that was part of
the investigation came and sat next to
him on the stoop right and he had shiny
shoes on Arthur had shiny shoes and like
he looked quite smart and because this
investigation was so wide-ranging the
cop came and sat next to him and started
sort of telling him about all of the
different things that were going on they
said I were to were looking for him
because he just presumed he's got shiny
shoes on he must be a policeman I mean
it just it I mean I interviewed poor
Beecham it brought my Hospital years ago
I didn't you'd ronnie kray as well funny
enough but ia be the mass murderer pool
it was a great artist he loved painting
we struck a good relationship and then
he met Wilma cool I think Paula riddles
worth it was a social work I went to the
Wynn to the hospital um and then he was
released but I'm you know and this is a
true story and he came to stay with me
at my cottage in encouraged in Hampshire
and we talked about painting we took my
two gun dogs I had guns funny I never
kept them in the garage what he was he
did but I went and when he went along
the river of Winchester and we talked
about stuff and then that night I went
to bed and in the morning the World Cup
and the kitchen was spotless and there
was a note saying Christopher I'll never
be as good artist as you he said I've
got to go now
I'm I've got to go enough is enough
but week later II he bludgeoned his wife
to death and buried her under the patio
then he took a shot gonna blow his head
off
now what I couldn't understand was when
I was visiting with Paul in the autumn
we were walking around the grounds that
brought more and there was a guy raking
up leaves and Paul said to me that man's
a psychiatrist I said no he's not Paul
reason one of your mates Renier locked
up he said Chris he's a Scot
he said he turns into a fly at night and
watches me
a picture he walks over to this guy took
the rake off and snaps around here
brother make they said he won't come
into my cell tonight and buzz around and
abroad more they let him out but then
you let him you let him into your house
yep
because there was something about Paul
that I felt very very safe with he was
very funny he had a very boyish laugh
about him but he was fascinated with all
the paintings and he produced some of
the most beautiful copy or paints and I
had one for years actually the green
lady and I am quite a well-known oil
painter as well and we both hit it off I
mean I hit it off with Peter sacrifice
meet us uh cliff was doing watercolor
watercolor
at the time in Broadmoor so we had that
thing about painting so you don't always
go in like a bull in a tire shop
sometimes it's finding out like I said
what bait to use I got that but letting
someone into your house that you know is
capable of this and by definition the
fact that within a week or a couple of
weeks later he then went committed a
crime committed suicide like it saw it
obviously it wasn't he hadn't rid
himself of this I've just again how'd
you keep coming back to the fact that I
can't it's a big pair of brass balls
that you've got on you well all I can
say is I was in the Marines for 11 years
and I don't give a rat's about anything
I was the green berry but the thing is
your viewers can look at Palm Beach and
be e e CH I am Pro beat him on Google he
while he was when he came out he was on
he was heavily sedated when he was
released under the supervision he
married this woman by the way and then
he started when we were walking along
the river he sits there watching me all
the time he said in mind a sign writing
business and he said Chris they watch
him all the time they talk about it in
the local pubs me he said mom mom why
she she's got a Bentley on the back
and she had two sons fair enough and
they she said well I think you ought to
sit down but my book wasn't tell him
what your history is I know and he did
he sat down with his two sons and told
he's a mass killer then he'd come out
broad bore and they accepted him he was
a good dad he turned into a good dad but
he was just schizophrenic and when the
medication wore off and he refused to
take more medication it became more
schizophrenic more paranoid I met him in
that period where he was and what we
were doing we were a form of escapism
with the paintings we talked about
canvases pigments brushes Sables bristle
brushes palettes we talked about it you
know and he loved dogs so that was him
but after he cleaned up the kitchen tidy
and he left a note meant a lot to me I
think the crazy thing to take away or at
least one of the things I'm taking away
is that these people are so multifaceted
you look at you look at someone like
that gentleman or Ted Bundy or this John
Robinson or whoever it might be
and I think it it seems safer to presume
that they are across the board crazy
that you would be able to pick them out
a mile off because they'd be walking
down the street pulling the heads off
birds and wearing a big yellow t-shirt
dancing upside down but I think the fact
that someone who's capable of that sort
of atrocity is also capable of doing
good watercolor and will clean your
kitchen and leave you a note saying
thank you in the morning the fact that
you have that juxtaposition between the
incredibly normal and the incredibly
abnormal I think that's that's what
that's what's really disturbing me I
think Paulie was generally mentally ill
Peter Sutcliffe calmed himself into
Broadmoor he wasn't mentally ill he
calmed the psychiatrist there for years
before they moved into a secure prison
because he was too mouthy
he wasn't mentally or but but Paul Paul
Bateson was mentally ill there's no
doubt about that at all he was a sick
man
and you know I have to have some
compassion for somebody that is mentally
or biggity is not there a problem
he's not he wasn't a psychopath he
wasn't evil in the sense that we that he
went out to rape and kill and torture
people he just felt that their worms
inside his head eating inside his head
you that is a sad situation to be in and
I've got every sympathy for somebody
like that so I felt safe with him I knew
where we were together you know but but
the scum that I work with generally and
research and write about are
just pure evil they're in control of
their faculties they know what they're
doing they know why they're doing it
yeah understand 100% and you know you
could be sitting on a woman could be
sitting on a bus and the man could be
watching her from the seat back next day
he might she might see him again in the
supermarket thing I saw him on the bus
and God could be a stalker
I've just written a book about homicides
talking comes out next you did you are
on this later at the moment well I've
got another 45 books to write I mean I'm
a brand that willing to battle now so
I'm in the I just can't believe it I
mean I've never written a book for money
I wrote my first book about Craig and
Bentley years ago cool dad help me
please Robin Odell the criminal of the
great writer and when this league title
like teaching me the ropes but I was the
lead author that book got Derek Bentley
a posthumous pardon
it made the film late and have it
starring Christopher Eccleston
and the following year it was the
Reader's Digest nonfiction hardback
number-one title and I think after the
stress of that I thought I never walk
again about 38 books later you're a
glutton for punishment Christopher I
have to say you know you write walking
through WH Smith especially because of
the way that your covers are designed
I think the talking with serial killers
stuff particularly really stands out I
don't know what it is about it's very
grabbing that's a brand years ago 2001
2003 I've done all these serial killer
interviews and I approached a number of
publishers one with Virgie knew I'd been
published with before to say that I've
got I'm going to use all the killer's
own words in this law and in those days
I mean the serial killer series we made
and then 12 part series led by maple
Fraser Ashford they they've never ever
been imprisoned before you yeah we broke
the mold of the weed with ones are
sitting there with the killer's face to
face and it never been done before
that was the ground breaker and then I
wrote this book and of course the virgin
turn around and said to me over the
phone and well Chris I'm sorry but it's
not for us really it's not a sort of
book it might upset our ladies with gray
winces and then ten minutes later John
Blake phone me
he said I have it he took a break move
because the first time book ever been
published in criminal history that
contained the killer's own terrible
words then an hour later virgin ran back
I said we've reconsidered we'll have
that book I said sorry I'll fold it that
was John it was John Blake who who came
up with talking with the talk of the
serial killers brand if you like and now
it's that's what it is
so they define I am the mad thing is the
serial killer true crime obsession
appears to skew quite heavily female in
my knowledge in any case so virgin
perhaps letting that one slide perhaps
that was exactly the sort of thing they
needed to just reignite their ladies
with the gray rinses and get them back
into the book one thing I'm always paid
to stress in or on their books is
empathy and sadness and for the grieving
next-of-kin I think you can never ever
make these people it was a movie called
Bundy Ted Bundy the American icon
I can't I didn't what does icon mean you
know they're not isn't all iconic it's
just a scumbag but the thing is I've
always got this thing because when I
interviewed after school crossing about
gently I've been to see his sister and
his / her family and they lived in a
little little place was a bit of a tip
and they went out and they got some
British team
at a camera crew with me and their
sisterly family were there and she gone
out with her hair down Chris especially
and she said to me could you please try
to get out she said I know Arthur hasn't
killed Josh she said because every day
we look out the window and on with we're
going to see Jack walk down the road one
day
well like that's why I got that
confession a general chalk ostrich
angling and I went back to his sister
and a family and they were shaking and I
said to the camera crew outside and I
sat down with her and she burst into
tears
when I did one a girl could listen more
down in Texas with Arthur Shawcross I
interviewed the mother the body hadn't
been recovered
I was Kendall tough little girl and I
sat with her and her husband in a motel
with a crew and she told me that she'd
been walking around the dirt roads of
Texas every night with a spade looking
for a child she was a wreck I've got her
to look at the camera and plead with my
death please give me my daughter back as
your mother would want your body back
after you're gone
and I went to I got a confession one of
my books I wheedle the confession out of
him and we found the body trussed up in
the drain hole within a hundred yards of
a freeway where if she screamed Noble
you'd have heard her is a cool little
kid trussed up I went back to her mum
and I said we found your daughter and
her mother burst into tears and I went
outside and I smoked I must have had
about 20 cigarettes in ten minutes
[Laughter]
and I started to cry because I've got
daughters and I've got a little boy and
her husband put his arm around my
shoulders and he said god bless you he
said you've just done you've done it all
for us thank you
now even if all of that all my writing
career just brings one result like that
I'm happy
period it's a normal course I honestly
that closure bringing some end you know
to the torture of not knowing for
families like that it's worth the time
it's definitely worth all of the time
and the effort and the date well the
danger that you put yourself in still
blows me away a point I never wrote the
money I wrote that first book because I
wanted to I wrote my second book we
longed Rock because my grandfather one
of the lawyers in the crater in the
murder of PC cartridge in Essex in 1937
a rhotic as it fascinated me I wrote it
because I was an intelligence officer in
the Marines and I knew how to
interrogate unknown to get inside
people's head I knew about certain
amount about torture and I knew it and I
thought to myself this is so fascinating
but I never ever you can't write like
this and research like this and do these
things finishing you want to because the
money you never get you wouldn't get it
back by the grace of God I've had some
bestsellers that's all it is and that's
because my publishers and their laws and
their promotion people I'm just there
one of I just pushed the Penton around I
tell Toby buck in my effective editor
and he lured buck inert we smear his
grandfather was Sir John Buccaneer Oh 39
steps we've been together a lot four or
five books now I'm just part of a team
that's all one is and the most important
part of the team the people that watch
you all podcast and the people that buy
our books
are the most important and we must never
forget that what a lovely way to end
Christopher thank you so much I think
it's a really nice way to put it across
as well like the fact that as you say
pursuing something which is difficult
and challenging and worthwhile and has
this higher calling and you haven't
you're adept at it and it brings across
more you know how much value millions
and millions and millions of pounds
billions of pounds for that one woman to
have that closure there is no price that
you could put on being able to bring
that to someone and there is no amount
of books that you could have sold that
would have matched the amount of
satisfaction and pleasure and sense of
purpose that you derive from being able
to give that to someone when I was being
interviewed by an Australian firm
recently I get the TV company came over
to interview me and it's the same stuff
questioned Christopher does this ever
affect that you and I say no and they
said one up I shall come from Portsmouth
[Laughter]
well I I don't know what I don't know
what to say Portsmouth I've been to
Portsmouth once but yeah well I probably
wouldn't mess about too much done there
look Christopher it's been awesome level
talking with serial killers dead men
talking death rows worst killers in
their own words will be linked in the
show notes below pick it up on Amazon
is there a audible versions and stuff
like that as well I'll say yeah we've
got some audible versions out there
talking books around but I don't think
it's that title got you okay it'll be
loud there are two bye hang on there
were two boy yeah these ones
Colin Mase okay he he's done these
talking books and I'll tell you what
he's got me two team brilliant look I
love it look at Christopher thank you so
much for your time I really appreciate
your first podcast you've done
fantastically well I absolutely love the
book everyone that's listening you need
to go and check it out it's fascinating
I really like the
the idea of you serving a higher cause
as well with this Christopher I think
putting your talents to use and I loved
every second of this and all I want to
say to you is sweet dreams and no
nightmares please I'm gonna try thank
you so much for your time man I'll catch
you later on
god bless bye
[Music]
you